Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode contains violence against children that won't be suitable for all listeners. The Corrunda Highway is a 172km long roadway that connects the South Australian Riverside Township of Murray Bridge with Lockston, further north, on the cusp of the state's border with Victoria.
我们的节目涉及严重且常常令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要帮助，请联系您当地的危机中心。关于保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目简介。今天的节目包含不适合所有听众的针对儿童的暴力内容。科伦达高速公路是一条长172公里的公路，连接南澳大利亚州河畔小镇墨累桥和更北边的洛克斯顿，该处靠近该州与维多利亚州的边界。
Largely desolate, the highway cuts through expensive agricultural landscapes with several remote houses and small towns dotted along the way, including Warnarka. Situated 105km east of the capital city of Adelaide, Warnarka's main street offers little but a post office, fire station and a public pay phone, plus a football oval and tennis courts nearby. With a population of fewer than 100 people, it's the kind of town where anything out of place is noticed. By mid-March 2015, roadworks along a stretch of the Corrunda Highway two kilometres east
这条公路大部分荒凉无人，穿过广阔的农业景观，沿途点缀着几栋偏僻的房屋和小镇，其中包括瓦纳卡。瓦纳卡距离首府阿德莱德以东105公里，其主街上几乎只有一家邮局、消防局和公共公用电话亭，附近还有一个椭圆形足球场和网球场。这里的人口不到100人，是一个任何不寻常的事情都会被注意到的城镇。到2015年3月中旬，科伦达高速公路位于瓦纳卡以东两公里路段的道路施工已经完工。
of Warnarka were completed. Shortly afterwards, a large grey suitcase was sighted on the roadside. It appeared as though it had fallen off a passing truck. Unbleached, stained and dirty from having been exposed to the elements for an extended period of time, the Lanza brand suitcase caught the attention of multiple highway travellers, with one stopping to investigate. Upon partially emptying the bag behind a bush and realising it contained soiled children's clothing infested with insects, they disregarded the find and dragged the bag back to the roadside.
不久之后，路边出现了一个灰色的皮箱。它看起来像是从过往的卡车上掉落的。这个Lanza品牌的皮箱因长期暴露在恶劣天气中而变得未漂白、有污渍且肮脏，引起了多名公路旅行者的注意，其中一人停下来查看。当他们在灌木丛后半倒出包里的东西，发现里面装满了沾有粪便且虫子滋生的儿童衣物时，便不再理会这个发现，并将箱子拖回了路边。
On Tuesday July 14, 2015, a motorist travelling down the highway pulled over to relieve himself. As he made his way into the thick bushland framing the side of the road, he noticed an array of dirty and torn children's clothing strewn under a patch of trees. In front was the abandoned suitcase. He crouched down to unzip the case and rummaged through its contents for himself, noticing a small human jawbone. The suitcase contained the heavily decomposed remains of a young child. National news outlets theorised that was missing Australian boy William Tyrell.
2015年7月14日星期二，一名行驶在该公路上的司机把车停在路边准备小便。当他走进路边茂密的灌木丛时，发现一丛树下散落着许多肮脏且破损的儿童衣物。最前方就是那个被遗弃的皮箱。他蹲下来拉开箱子的拉链，翻找着里面的东西，发现了一根小巧的人类下颌骨。皮箱里装着一具严重腐烂的幼儿遗骸。国家新闻媒体推测这正是失踪的澳大利亚男孩威廉·泰瑞尔。
In September the year prior, three-year-old William was playing in the yard of his foster grandmother's house in New South Wales when he suddenly vanished. Ongoing search and investigative efforts had failed to turn up any trace of William, and although police had yet to conclude what had happened to him, the general consensus was the boy had been abducted. International media cast a wider net, suggesting the remains in the suitcase were those of missing English girl Madeline McCann. The three-year-old was at the centre of modern history's most reported-on missing person
在前一年的9月，三岁的威廉正在新南威尔士州寄养祖母家的院子里玩耍，突然神秘失踪。持续的搜寻和调查工作未能找到威廉的任何踪迹，尽管警方尚未对他的遭遇得出最终结论，但普遍的共识是这个男孩被绑架了。国际媒体将范围扩大，暗示皮箱中的遗骸属于失踪的英国女孩玛德琳·麦肯。这个三岁女孩是现代历史上被报道最多的失踪人口案件的中心人物
case after she disappeared from her family's holiday apartment in Portugal in May 2007. All scenarios and suspects had been considered over the years, including the possibility she was abducted by a pedophile ring and transported overseas. Speculation ended at the conclusion of a post-mortem. The child was an unknown Caucasian female aged between two and four years old, approximately 90 centimetres tall with shoulder-length, fair-coloured hair. Two balls of blue and white striped dishcloth were tucked inside her mouth, which had been sealed with silver duct tape.
2007年5月，她在葡萄牙的度假公寓失踪。多年来，所有的假设和嫌疑人都被考虑过，包括她被恋童癖团伙绑架并运往海外的可能性。在一份尸检报告得出结论后，这些猜测终于平息。死者是一个身份不明的高加索女童，年龄在两到四岁之间，身高约90厘米，留着肩长的浅色头发。她的嘴里塞着两个蓝白相间的洗碗布球，并用银色胶带封住。
There was no injury to the skeletal remains, and in the absence of soft tissue, a cause of death could not be determined, although asphyxiation was presumed. It was believed she had been deceased for upwards of seven years, killed elsewhere before her body was stored in the suitcase within a month, and discarded on the roadside where it remained until discovery. The girl's skull was covered with a disposable nappy, and a purple, down-underbrand bath towel was wrapped around the lower part of her torso. South Australia's Major Crime Investigation Branch established Task Force Mali to oversee
骨骼遗骸没有受伤的痕迹，由于缺乏软组织，死因无法确定，不过推测是窒息身亡。据信她已经死亡七年之久，在被运到别处杀害后，她的尸体在一个月内被装入皮箱，并被丢弃在路边，直到被发现一直留在那儿。女孩的头骨上盖着一块一次性尿布，下半身包裹着一条紫色的澳洲品牌浴巾。南澳大利亚州重大犯罪调查局成立了马利专案组来监督
the case, fronted by Detective Superintendent Des Bray. He withheld details of the autopsy from the media, but told ABC News reporters that the child, quote, died of violent death under terrible circumstances. The media dubbed the unknown girl the Angel of Wanaka, and to the roadside where her remains were found was memorialised with flowers, teddy bears, and messages of grief. One read, You deserved better than this. Rest in peace, little angel.
该案由侦探总警司德斯·布雷负责。他向媒体隐瞒了尸检的细节，但告诉澳大利亚广播公司新闻记者，这个孩子“在可怕的情况下死于暴力”。媒体将这个身份不明的女孩称为“瓦纳卡的天使”，在她遗骸被发现的路边，人们摆放了鲜花、泰迪熊和悲痛的留言来纪念她。其中一条写着：“你本该得到更好的对待。安息吧，小天使。”
Task Force Mali questioned every resident of Wanaka and learned of an incident in early May that had been a source of intrigue in the small town. One morning, when two Wanaka residents were walking their dogs outside town, they rounded the dusty track along the railway line and sighted a clean-cut man neatly dressed in a suit. He was Caucasian about 60 years old with grey hair and was of average height and build. The man was walking alone down the road with a large, dark-coloured suitcase. Without looking up, he crossed the train tracks into the scrub towards the Karunda Highway.
马利专案组盘问了瓦纳卡的所有居民，得知5月初发生了一起在小镇上引起好奇的事件。一天早晨，当两名瓦纳卡居民在镇外遛狗时，他们绕过铁路线旁尘土飞扬的小路，看到了一名穿着整洁西装的干净男子。他是一名高加索人，大约60岁，灰色头发，中等身高和体型。这名男子独自一人走在路上，提着一个黑色的大皮箱。他没有抬头，径直穿过铁路线，走向卡伦达高速公路方向的灌木丛。
The dog walkers described feeling an unnerving sixth sense about the suited stranger. He was heading away from town and opted to carry his bulky suitcase as opposed to pulling it along by its handle. This sighting didn't align perfectly with the timeline established, as the first sightings of the suitcase on the roadside occurred in March, with the suited man witnessed more than a month later. Nevertheless, a connection was drawn and police appealed to the public to identify him. Images of the children's clothing found with the remains were released to the media, including
遛狗的人描述说，他们对这个穿西装的陌生人有一种令人不安的第六感。他正朝着远离小镇的方向走去，而且选择用手提着笨重的皮箱，而不是用拉杆拖着走。这起目击事件与已确定的时间线并不完全吻合，因为路边首次出现皮箱是在3月份，而穿西装的男子被目击则在一个多月之后。尽管如此，警方还是将两者联系起来，并呼吁公众协助辨认此人。媒体公布了随遗骸一起发现的儿童衣物的照片，包括
a black dress with sequined tutu, a pink striped dress, silk boxer shorts, Dora the Explorer pajama pants, pink track pants, a cream fur-trimmed coat, and a single pink slipper with a butterfly motif on the toe. There was also a 90 by 90-centimeter patchwork quilt featuring a black border of colourful music notes. Although badly deteriorated, police were able to reconstruct seven of the quilt's 25 octagonal patches. They contained images of butterflies, geckos, dogs, a camel, a pumpkin patch, and stars.
一件带有亮片芭蕾短裙的黑色连衣裙、一条粉红色条纹连衣裙、丝绸平角短裤、爱探险的朵拉睡裤、粉红色运动裤、一件带奶油色毛皮边缘的外套，以及一只脚趾上有蝴蝶图案的粉红色拖鞋。还有一条90乘90厘米的拼布被子，边缘镶有彩色音符的黑边。虽然已经严重损坏，但警方还是成功重构了该被子25块八角形拼布中的7块。上面有蝴蝶、壁虎、狗、骆驼、南瓜地和星星的图案。
The fabric had been manufactured in New York seven years earlier, but the quilt itself was handmade and machined stitched. Investigators believed the one-off item was crafted by someone close to the child, and may have been used as a teaching tool to help them identify the animals and objects on the patches. The black sequined tutu dress was one of 28 sold exclusively in store by fashion brand cotton on kids throughout South Australia eight years prior. As it was no longer feasible to trace the item back to the victim, investigators believed
这种织物七年前在纽约制造，但被子本身是手工制作并用机器缝制的。调查人员认为，这件独一无二的物品是由与孩子关系密切的人制作的，可能曾被用作教学工具，帮助他们识别拼布上的动物和物体。那件带有黑色亮片的芭蕾短裙是时尚品牌Cotton On Kids八年前在南澳大利亚州全境独家出售的28件服装之一。由于追踪该物品到受害者的可能性已经不大，调查人员认为
the key to identifying the girl hinged on the one-of-a-kind quilt. Superintendent Des Bray told the media, "'Someone loved that little girl and either made her or gave her that quilt. I would appeal for whoever loved her to get in touch with us.'" Attempts to identify the child continued for weeks. Police extended their line of questioning to towns within a 250 square kilometer radius of Wanaka, as officers on horseback canvassed the terrain for 48 kilometers from the side of the discovery.
识别该女孩身份的关键取决于这条独一无二的被子。总警司德斯·布雷对媒体表示：“‘有人爱着那个小女孩，要么为她制作了这条被子，要么把这条被子送给了她。我呼吁所有爱她的人与我们联系。’”确认儿童身份的尝试持续了数周。警方将询问范围扩大到距离瓦纳卡250平方公里半径内的城镇，骑警们在发现地点周围48公里的地形中进行地毯式搜寻。
Attempts provided dashcam footage taken along the Karunda Highway over previous years, revealing the suitcase had been moved and examined multiple times before it was finally reported to police. All 145 children from Australia's missing persons register had been ruled out, opening up the possibility that the victim's birth was unregistered, or that they were indeed from another country. Chief Inspector Greg Hutchins told the media he had never seen a murder like this in his 37 years of service, quote, "'This truly is a little girl lost.
搜寻工作提供了过去几年沿卡伦达高速公路拍摄的行车记录仪画面，显示皮箱在最终被举报给警方之前，曾被多次移动和检查。澳大利亚失踪人口登记册上的所有145名儿童已被排除，这引发了受害者出生未登记，或者他们确实来自另一个国家的可能性。高级督察格雷格·哈钦斯对媒体表示，在他37年的职业生涯中，从未见过这样的谋杀案，他说：“‘这真是一个迷失的小女孩。”
She seems to be lost to society, lost to the system, forgotten by all. And that is incredibly sad.'" As the investigation reached its third month, Superintendent Des Bray announced, It's hard to believe someone hasn't missed her. I thought when we started this job that we would quickly identify who this little girl was. Somewhere out there is a mother, a father, at the very least an extended family, and I'm at a loss as to why someone hasn't reported this little girl.
她似乎被社会遗忘，被系统遗忘，被所有人遗忘。这真是令人难以置信的悲伤。’随着调查进入第三个月，总警司德斯·布雷宣布：“很难相信没有人会想念她。我以为当我们开始这项工作时，我们会很快确定这个小女孩是谁。在某个地方一定有一位母亲、一位父亲，至少还有一个大家庭，我实在想不通为什么没有人报告这个小女孩失踪。”
On Tuesday, October 6, 2015, call number 1267 was placed to the crime stopper's hotline from a woman named Tanya Weber. Tanya lived over 1600 kilometres from Winarka, in the remote Northern Territory town of Alice Springs, and had been following the Angel of Winarka case. She recognised some of the child's clothing, but her concerns peaked when she saw the patchwork quilt, as it bore similarities to one that had been handcrafted by her best friend, Colleen Povey. Several photos of Colleen Povey's granddaughter, two-year-old Candelice Pierce, were supplied
2015年10月6日星期二，一名叫塔尼娅·韦伯的女子拨打了灭罪热线，电话编号为1267。塔尼娅住在距离瓦纳卡1600多公里远的北领地偏远小镇艾丽斯斯普林斯，一直在关注“瓦纳卡的天使”一案。她认出了孩子的一些衣物，但当她看到那条拼布被子时，心中的担忧达到了顶点，因为它与她的好朋友科琳·波维手工制作的一条被子有相似之处。科琳·波维的孙女、两岁的坎德利斯·皮尔斯的几张照片被提供给了
to Task Force Malley. The toddler had pale blonde hair, and in one image she was wearing a pink striped dress similar to one found with the unidentified remains. The toddler showed Candelice in a stroller clutching a Rubik's cube. Tucked behind her was a patchwork quilt with a black border of colourful musical notes, an exact match to the one found with the Angel of Winarka. Tanya Weber explained that Candelice was taken into state seven years earlier by her then-20-year-old mother, Carly Pierce Stevenson.
马利专案组。这个幼儿有着淡金色的头发，在一张照片中，她穿着一件粉红色条纹连衣裙，类似于在未名遗骸旁发现的一件。照片显示坎德利斯坐在婴儿车里，手里拿着一个魔方。她身后藏着一条边缘带有彩色音符黑边的拼布被子，这与在“瓦纳卡的天使”身旁发现的那条完全吻合。塔尼娅·韦伯解释说，坎德利斯七年前被她当时20岁的母亲卡莉·皮尔斯·史蒂文森带入了州内。
Take-named mouse for her short stature and petite features, Carly became pregnant at age 18 and gave birth to Candelice, known affectionately as Candles, on June 19, 2006. Carly took on motherhood seriously. She was fully supported and assisted by her family, however, a disagreement with her mother soon prompted Carly to seek independence and work elsewhere. In November 2008, Carly abruptly announced that she and Candelice were moving to Adelaide. She packed their belongings into her 1996 Holden Commodore station wagon and left. After a brief stop in the town of Port Augusta to visit Carly's grandmother, the pair continued
卡莉因为个子矮小和娇小的外貌而被昵称为“小老鼠”，她在18岁时怀孕，并于2006年6月19日生下了坎德利斯，小名亲切地叫作“蜡烛”。卡莉认真地承担起了母亲的责任。她得到了家人的全力支持和协助，然而，与母亲的一次争执很快促使卡莉寻求独立并到别处工作。2008年11月，卡莉突然宣布她和坎德利斯要搬到阿德莱德去。她把行李打包进自己的1996款霍顿准将旅行车，然后离开了。在皮里港小镇短暂停留以拜访卡莉的祖母后，两人继续
onwards to Adelaide and spent a day at Marion Shopping Centre with an old friend. Shortly a week into their trip, Carly called family friend Tanya Weber in tears, saying she had made a mistake and wanted to come home. Tanya offered to pay for her flight or arranged to have someone pick her up, but Carly declined. By the end of their conversation, she seemed to have calmed down and was back to her happy self. Tanya tried contacting Carly numerous times after that, but she never answered. Over the coming months, family and friends progressively heard less from Carly and calls
前往阿德莱德，并与一位老朋友在马里昂购物中心度过了一天。旅行大约一周后，卡莉哭着打电话给家庭朋友塔尼娅·韦伯，说她犯了一个错误，想回家。塔尼娅提出为她支付机票费用或安排人接她，但卡莉拒绝了。在谈话结束时，她似乎已经平静下来，恢复了往日快乐的自己。此后，塔尼娅多次试图联系卡莉，但她从未接听。在接下来的几个月里，家人和朋友逐渐听不到卡莉的消息，电话
stopped entirely after a year. Her Facebook page also appeared abandoned. On September 4, 2009, Colleen reported her daughter and granddaughter missing. Parents confirmed Carly was using her bank account regularly, with the most recent transaction occurring days earlier at an ATM in South Australia. Police made some phone calls and were informed that Carly was planning to move north to Queensland with a new boyfriend. Certain Carly and Candelise were fine.
在一年后彻底中断。她的脸书页面也荒废了。2009年9月4日，科琳报告她的女儿和孙女失踪。父母确认卡莉一直在定期使用她的银行账户，最近一次交易发生在几天前南澳大利亚州的一台自动取款机上。警方打了一些电话，被告知卡莉正计划带着新男友向北搬到昆士兰州。警方确信卡莉和坎德利斯安然无恙。
The police nevertheless agreed to keep their file open until someone directly saw or spoke with the pair. According to reports, Colleen contacted the police again six days later, explaining she had received a phone call from Carly. Sounding strange and speaking in a whisper, Carly refused to disclose where she and Candelise were living, but reassured her mother that everything was fine. She also expressed a desire not to be contacted again. This report was disputed by Carly's family, who later stated it was the police who claimed
尽管如此，警方还是同意保持档案开放，直到有人直接看到或与两人交谈。据报道，科琳在六天后再次联系警方，解释说她接到了卡莉的电话。卡莉的声音听起来很奇怪，说话时压低了嗓门，拒绝透露她和坎德利斯住在哪里，但向母亲保证一切都很好。她还表达了不想再次被联系的愿望。这一报告遭到卡莉家人的反驳，他们后来表示，是警方声称
to have spoken with Carly on the phone and following her comments announced they would be closing the investigation into her disappearance. Five days later, Colleen received a text message from her daughter requesting money and she transferred her $500. Over the following years, family and friends received sporadic text messages from Carly needing money for various reasons, from travel expenses to buying Candelise a birthday present. Her mother obliged every request in the hopes the two would eventually return to Alice Springs. In February 2012, Colleen passed away from breast cancer at the age of 44.
在电话中与卡莉交过话，并在她的言论之后宣布将关闭对她失踪案的调查。五天后，科琳收到女儿发来的一条要求给钱的短信，并给她转了500美元。在接下来的几年里，家人和朋友零星地收到卡莉发来的短信，因各种原因需要钱，从旅行费用到给坎德利斯买生日礼物不等。她的母亲满足了每一个要求，希望两人最终能回到艾丽斯斯普林斯。2012年2月，科琳因乳腺癌去世，享年44岁。
Shortly before her death, she asked, Are Carly and Candelise here yet? But, her wish to be reunited with her daughter and granddaughter before she died went unfulfilled. In 2013, Carly's cousin wrote and published a Facebook post for Carly, which read, To my beautiful cousin, I know you're somewhere out there and I just want you to know I won't stop looking for you. If you see this, or if anyone has seen this girl, please let me know. Not a day goes by that I don't think of you both. I just want to know you're both safe.
在她去世前不久，她问道：“卡莉和坎德利斯回来了吗？”但是，她在临死前希望能与女儿和孙女团聚的愿望最终未能实现。2013年，卡莉的表妹为卡莉写并发布了一条脸书帖子，上面写着：“我美丽的表妹，我知道你就在某个地方，我只是想让你知道我不会停止寻找你。如果你看到了这个，或者任何人见过这个女孩，请告诉我。没有一天我不在想念你们俩。我只想知道你们俩是否平安。”
Candelise's medical records were sparse. Her last doctor visit occurred when she was 18 months old to receive immunizations. There were no further records after that, nor had she been registered with education authorities or childcare facilities anywhere throughout Australia. As per standard procedure, when Candelise was born, several drops of blood were drawn from her heel for routine screening. The sample had been stored and was compared to DNA from the remains in the suitcase, revealing a match.
坎德利斯的医疗记录非常少。她最后一次看医生是在她18个月大时去接种疫苗。此后没有任何进一步的记录，她也没有在澳大利亚任何地方的教育机构或托儿所注册。按照标准程序，坎德利斯出生时，从她的脚后跟抽取了几滴血用于常规筛查。该样本已被保存，并与皮箱中遗骸的DNA进行了比对，结果显示相符。
The Angel of Wanaka was two-year-old Candelise Pierce. Before any announcement was made to the public, a search for Candelise's mother, Carly, was initiated. Five years earlier in New South Wales, on the afternoon of Sunday, August 29, 2010, a group of trail bike riders were navigating through the heavily wooded area of Daly's Waterhole in the Blango State Forest. As they sped around a bend, one of the riders overshot the corner and entered a small clearing, where he spotted what appeared to be a large leg bone.
“瓦纳卡的天使”就是两岁的坎德利斯·皮尔斯。在向公众发布任何公告之前，对坎德利斯母亲卡莉的搜寻工作已经展开。五年前的新南威尔士州，2010年8月29日星期日午后，一群山地自行车骑手正在布兰戈州立森林中黛利水坑的茂密林区穿行。当他们呼啸着绕过一个弯道时，其中一名骑手冲过了弯道，进入了一片小空地，在那里他发现了疑似一块大腿骨的东西。
The group investigated further, finding a ribcage, spine, pelvis and a human skull, along with various items of clothing. Police arrived and sealed the area off as a crime scene. It appeared as though the body had initially been buried, but was later upturned by the roots of a nearby fallen tree. The discovery immediately stirred memories of the backpacker murders 18 years earlier, covered in episode 109 of Case Fire. Between 1989 and 1992, seven backpackers were abducted while hitchhiking from Sydney and
这群人进一步调查，发现了胸腔、脊椎、骨盆和人类头骨，以及各种衣物。警方赶到并将该地区封锁为犯罪现场。尸体似乎最初是被埋葬的，但后来被附近一棵倒下的树的树根翻了出来。这一发现立即勾起了18年后背包客谋杀案的回忆，该案在《案件解密》第109集中有报道。在1989年至1992年期间，七名背包客在从悉尼搭便车时被绑架并
violently killed in Belanglo. Local road worker Ivan Malat was sentenced to life in prison for the murders of James Gibson, Deborah Everest, Simone Schmidel, Gabor Neugebauer, Anya Habsheed, Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark. Yet many believed he was responsible for other unsolved disappearances and murders. A lingering dread permeated over Belanglo ever since the killings, with suspicions that more of Malat's victims lay undiscovered in the forest. The skeletal remains at Daley's Waterhole shared notable similarities to Malat's crime
在贝朗洛惨遭杀害。当地筑路工人伊万·马拉特因谋杀詹姆斯·吉布森、黛博拉·埃弗雷斯特、西蒙娜·施密德尔、加博尔·诺伊格鲍尔、安娅·哈布希德、乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克而被判处终身监禁。然而，许多人认为他还应对其他未破的失踪和谋杀案负责。自这些谋杀案发生以来，挥之不去的恐惧便笼罩着贝朗洛，人们怀疑森林中还躺着马拉特更多的受害者。戴利水坑的骨骼遗骸与马拉特的犯罪
scenes, prompting speculation that the trail bike riders had stumbled across another one of the serial killer's victims. Malat was known for making little effort to conceal his victims' remains, often leaving them alongside boulders or logs and haphazardly covering them in a light layer of forest debris. Yet, his known victims were discovered in a remote area of dense forest to the north. The newly uncovered remains were further south, in a more accessible area close to well-worn tracks. Investigators were hesitant to prematurely draw links to Malat and refused to even mention
现场有着惊人的相似之处，这引发了人们的猜测，即越野摩托车手可能偶然发现了这名连环杀手的又一个受害者。马拉特以极少费心掩盖受害者遗骸而闻名，他经常将尸体留在巨石或圆木旁，并随手用一层薄薄的森林杂物将其盖住。然而，他已知的受害者是在北部偏远的密林深处被发现的。新发现的遗骸位于更南边，是一个更易接近、靠近常用小径的区域。调查人员对过早地与马拉特建立联系持谨慎态度，甚至拒绝提及
his name to reporters. Alluding to the increasing conjecture, Superintendent Evan Quarmy remarked, We definitely will not be jumping to conclusions. There are many lines of investigation to explore. We are chasing facts. We are not chasing assumptions. Where those facts lead us is where our investigation will continue. The remains were those of an unknown female aged between 13 and 25 years, approximately
他的名字告诉记者。针对日益增多的猜测，欧文·夸尔米总督察评论道：“我们绝对不会妄下结论。有许多调查方向需要探索。我们在追寻事实，我们不是在追寻假设。事实将指引我们的调查继续进行。”遗骸属于一名年龄在13岁至25岁之间的未知女性，身高约
150 to 160 cm tall, with shoulder-length hair. She had sustained blunt force trauma to her torso, with fractures to multiple ribs on both sides of the chest. Although the exact cause of her death could not be determined, her injury strongly correlated with the application of compressive force by way of stomping or kneeling. The remains had been in the forest from anywhere between 6 months to 10 years, a time frame that ruled Ivan Malat out as a possible perpetrator, as he had been arrested in 1994. As police examined missing person files across Australia, a DNA profile was extracted from
150至160厘米，留着齐肩发。她的躯干曾遭受钝器伤，胸腔两侧多根肋骨骨折。虽然无法确定具体的死因，但她的伤势与通过踩踏或跪压施加的挤压力的行为高度吻合。这些遗骸在森林中存放的时间在6个月到10年之间，这个时间范围排除了伊万·马拉特作为作案者的可能性，因为他已于1994年被捕。正当警方查阅全澳大利亚的失踪人员档案时，从
the victim's tibia bone and uploaded to the National Criminal Investigation Database. This allowed the sample to be cross-checked against others collected from crime scenes, convicted offenders, suspects, and missing persons, yet there was no match. As her teeth showed signs of dentistry carried out in Australia, detectives made inquiries with dentists local to the Southern Highlands region, but to no avail. Focus shifted to a badly decomposed t-shirt found near the remains. The white size 10 shirt featured a motif of a rose, heart, and angel wings, with the word angelic written above in pink text.
受害者的胫骨中提取了DNA谱，并上传至国家刑事调查数据库。这使得该样本能够与从犯罪现场、被定罪的罪犯、嫌疑人和失踪人员那里收集到的其他样本进行交叉比对，但没有找到匹配项。由于她的牙齿显示出曾在澳大利亚进行过牙科治疗的迹象，侦探们向南高地地区的当地牙医进行了询问，但无济于事。焦点转移到在遗骸附近发现的一件严重腐烂的T恤上。这件白色的10码T恤印有玫瑰、心脏和天使翅膀的图案，粉红色的字样写着“angelic”。
It was produced by fashion brand Chain Reaction and sold in retail stores throughout Australia in 2003. An artistic impression of the t-shirt was released to the public, with the motif inspiring the media to name the unidentified woman, the Angel of Belangelo. A facial anthropologist examined the skull to create an approximate image of what the Angel of Belangelo may have looked like at the time of her death. The image was circulated in the media and sent to law enforcement agencies overseas, but no one recognized her.
它由时尚品牌Chain Reaction生产，并于2003年在澳大利亚各地的零售店出售。这件T恤的艺术画像被公开发布，该图案激发了媒体将这位身份不明的女性命名为“贝朗洛的天使”。一位面部人类学家检查了头骨，以创建一张关于贝朗洛的天使生前可能长相的近似画像。这张画像在媒体上流传，并发送给海外的执法机构，但没有人认出她。
In November 2012, more than two years after the discovery, Western Australian law enforcement announced that they had received information that the woman may have been a European backpacker who worked for a vineyard in the Margaret River region. As the victim's death didn't align with Ivan Malat's killing spree, police considered the possibility that they were dealing with a copycat or someone hoping to cover up their own crime by pinning it on the serial killer. Other theories included that the Angel of Belangelo had been murdered by her domestic partner, had fallen under society's radar, been isolated with limited social connections, placed in
2012年11月，在发现遗体两年多后，西澳大利亚执法部门宣布，他们收到消息称，这名女性可能是一名欧洲背包客，曾在玛格丽特河地区的葡萄园工作。由于受害者的死与伊万·马拉特的连环杀戮不符，警方考虑了这样一种可能性：他们面对的是一个模仿作案者，或者是一个希望将罪名嫁祸给连环杀手以掩盖自己罪行的人。其他理论包括“贝朗洛的天使”是被其同居伴侣谋杀的、被社会忽视、社会联系有限且处于孤立状态、被送入
institutions, or engaged in sex work. Criminal psychologists believed the perpetrator was likely studying news reports to keep up to date with the investigation, with the crime constantly on their mind. But with no clear leads or major breakthroughs, the case went cold for five years. In 2015, following the discovery of Candelice Pierce's remains in the suitcase in South Australia, a sample of the two-year-old's DNA was sent to the Forensic and Analytical Science Service Centre in New South Wales. The whereabouts of her mother were still unknown, and police aimed to rule out the
机构，或者从事性工作。犯罪心理学家认为，作案者可能一直在研究新闻报道以了解调查的最新进展，这起犯罪一直萦绕在他们的脑海中。但由于没有明确的线索或重大突破，该案搁置了五年。2015年，在南澳大利亚的一个手提箱中发现坎德莉丝·皮尔斯的遗骸后，这份两岁女孩的DNA样本被送往新南威尔士州的法医和分析科学服务中心。她母亲的下落仍然未知，警方旨在排除
possibility that Carly may also be deceased by cross-checking Candelice's DNA with the collection of unidentified remains stored at the facility. Testing revealed that Candelice shared a familial match to the remains uncovered in Belangelo Forest in 2010. The pair were mother and daughter. The angel of Belangelo was 20-year-old Carly Pierce-Stevensson. Following the announcement that the angels of Winarka and Belangelo were two-year-old Candelice Pierce and her mother Carly Pierce-Stevensson, a statement from the pair's family expressed
通过将坎德莉丝的DNA与该机构储存的未识别遗骸集合进行交叉比对，卡莉也可能已经遇害的可能性。测试显示，坎德莉丝与2010年在贝朗洛森林中发现的遗骸存在亲缘匹配关系。两人是母女关系。贝朗洛的天使是20岁的卡莉·皮尔斯-史蒂文森。在宣布温卡和贝朗洛的天使是两岁女孩坎德莉丝·皮尔斯和她的母亲卡莉·皮尔斯-史蒂文森之后，这对母女的家属发表了一份声明，表达了
their devastation while thanking those involved in finally returning them home. A tribute for Carly by her stepfather Scott Povey and her brother Luke was later featured in the publication Northern Territory News at Red. Carly and Candles. The sun doesn't shine as bright as it did, but the night is now lit with a few more stars. No more looking to see if that girl is you as we saw someone else in a crowd. No more waiting to hear. No more waiting to see you show up smiling again as usual.
他们的悲痛，同时感谢那些最终让她们魂归故里的人。卡莉的继父斯科特·波维和她的弟弟卢克随后在《北领地新闻》红标版上发表了对卡莉的悼词。卡莉和坎德莉丝。阳光不如以往明亮，但夜晚现在点缀着更多的星星。再也不用去张望那个女孩是不是你，因为我们在人群中看到了别人。再也不用苦等消息。再也不用等待看你像往常一样带着微笑出现。
No more laughter, giggles and pranks. No more late nights just talking with the music playing. Our hearts have a thousand cuts and we will remain your strength. Give Candles a hug, sweetie. Love always, Dad and Luke. Superintendent Des Bray requested the public's assistance in finding the missing pieces of the puzzle, appealing to landlords, motel workers or caravan park owners who may have accommodated Carly and Candles prior to their deaths.
再也没有了欢笑、咯咯的笑声和恶作剧。再也没有伴随着音乐播放深夜畅谈。我们的心千疮百孔，我们将永远是你的支柱。给坎德莉丝一个拥抱，亲爱的。永远爱你的，爸爸和卢克。总督察德斯·布雷请求公众协助寻找拼图的缺失部分，呼吁可能在卡莉和坎德莉丝死前接待过她们的房东、汽车旅馆员工或大篷车公园业主提供线索。
Quote, This is one of the most shocking crimes imaginable and has torn apart and devastated a loving family. Those responsible for this crime are truly evil and remain amongst us in the community and must be held accountable for what they have done. Inquiries were made into how the pair met violent hands 1200km apart. It had since been brought to the attention of investigators that when Carly and Candles departed Alice Springs on Monday, November 10, 2008, they were not alone. They were accompanied by Carly's 34-year-old boyfriend Daniel Haldum.
引述：“这是最令人震惊的犯罪之一，它撕裂并摧毁了一个充满爱的家庭。对这起犯罪负有责任的人简直丧心病狂，他们依然在我们中间的社区里生活，必须为他们所做的一切承担责任。”调查人员对这对母女如何在相距1200公里的地方遭遇暴力毒手进行了调查。此后，调查人员注意到，当卡莉和坎德莉丝于2008年11月10日星期一离开爱丽丝斯普林斯时，她们并非孤身一人。她们由卡莉34岁的男友丹尼尔·哈尔杜姆陪同。
According to the book The Lost Girls by Ava Benny Morrison, Carly's mother, Carly had a bad feeling about Haldum and was unsure why her daughter would be interested in someone almost twice her age. Carly offered to look after Candles so the couple could make their journey to Adelaide alone, but Carly refused and the trio left the next day. Later that month, Haldum, Carly and Candles arrived to the outer suburb of Charnwood in the Australian capital of Canberra. There, the trio stayed with Haldum's cousin Christine for several weeks.
根据Ava Benny Morrison所著的《失踪女孩》一书，卡莉的母亲透露，卡莉对哈尔杜姆有一种不祥的预感，并且不明白为什么她的女儿会对一个年龄几乎大她一倍的人感兴趣。卡莉曾主动提出照顾坎德莉丝，以便这对情侣可以独自前往阿德莱德，但卡莉拒绝了，三人于第二天出发。当月晚些时候，哈尔杜姆、卡莉和坎德莉丝抵达了澳大利亚首都堪培拉的外围郊区查恩伍德。在那里，三人和哈尔杜姆的表妹克里斯蒂娜住在一起几个星期。
During that time, tension brewed between Carly and Haldum. At roughly 2.30 am on Monday, December 15, 2008, the couple left to go for a drive, leaving Candles in the care of Christine. After that day at around noon, Haldum returned alone with a scratch on his face. He said there had been a fight and Carly had asked to be dropped off at a bus stop. Christine was suspicious and asked how Carly could leave without her daughter. Haldum replied, sometimes she does that. Two days later, Haldum traded Carly's car for an older model Haldun statesman.
在那期间，卡莉和哈尔杜姆之间的关系日趋紧张。2008年12月15日星期一凌晨2点30分左右，两人开车外出兜风，将坎德尔交由克里斯蒂娜照顾。那天中午左右，哈尔杜姆独自一人返回，脸上带着抓伤。他说两人吵了一架，卡莉要求在公交车站下车。克里斯蒂娜感到怀疑，问卡莉怎么能抛下女儿独自离开。哈尔杜姆回答说，她有时会这么做。两天后，哈尔杜姆用卡莉的车换了一辆旧款的霍顿威廉王。
On Friday, December 19, he placed Candles into the statesman, telling his cousin he was taking the toddler to her grandmother's house in South Australia. When Colleen Povey reported Carly and Candles missing almost a year later, Northern Territory Police contacted Haldum in South Australia. He explained that he and Carly were no longer together and she was now seeing someone from Queensland. He offered to pass on her new contact number and asked the police to call him back later that afternoon.
12月19日星期五，他把坎德尔放进威廉王轿车里，告诉表弟他正带着这名幼儿去南澳大利亚州的祖母家。近一年后，科琳·波维报案称卡莉和坎德尔失踪，北领地警方随后联系了南澳州的哈尔杜姆。他解释说，他和卡莉已经分手，她现在正和昆士兰的一个人交往。他主动提出转达她的新联系电话，并请警方当天下午晚些时候再给他回电。
However, further attempts to reach him were unsuccessful. On June 24, 2010, a woman in a wheelchair entered a bank in Adelaide's Northern suburbs claiming to be Carly. She requested Carly's contact details be updated to an address in South Australia. That same month, Carly's identity was hijacked again when the same woman attended one of her compulsory Centrelink interviews in the North Adelaide suburb of Salisbury. She produced Candles' birth certificate in order to receive $8,000 in family tax benefits and rent assistance.
然而，随后的多次联系均未成功。2010年6月24日，一名坐轮椅的女子进入阿德莱德北部郊区的一家银行，声称自己是卡莉。她要求将卡莉的联系地址更新为南澳州的一个地址。同月，当同一名女子前往索尔兹伯里（北阿德莱德郊区）参加卡莉的强制性Centrelink面谈时，卡莉的身份再次被盗用。她出示了坎德尔的出生证明，以便领取8000美元的家庭税收福利和租金补贴。
Within Carly's network of friends and associates was a wheelchair-bound woman named Hazel Passmore who resided in Adelaide. She was a former girlfriend of Daniel Haldum. The pair commenced the relationship around 2005, with Haldum becoming stepfather to Hazel's three children, Lauren, Willow and Ryan. In mid-2007, the family relocated to Alice Springs and launched a car-detailing business dealing drugs on the side. There, they met and befriended Carly and Candleese.
在卡莉的朋友和熟人群中，有一位住在阿德莱德的坐轮椅女子，名叫黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔。她是丹尼尔·哈尔杜姆的前女友。两人于2005年左右开始交往，哈尔杜姆成为黑泽尔的三个孩子劳伦、威洛和瑞安的继父。2007年中期，这家人搬到了艾丽斯斯普林斯，开办了一家汽车美容业务，并在私底下贩毒。正是在那里，他们遇到了卡莉和坎德利斯并与之结为好友。
On Monday, September 15, 2008, Haldum, Hazel and their three children set out on a 16-hour drive to Adelaide. Haldum was yawning and struggling to stay alert, but he ignored Hazel's requests to pull over and rest. Suddenly, two kangaroos leapt out in front of the car. Haldum swerved, which caused the car to spin out of control and flip five times on its side. They emerged from the wreckage relatively unscathed, but Hazel's legs, torso and some
2008年9月15日星期一，哈尔杜姆、黑泽尔和他们的三个孩子踏上了开往阿德莱德的16小时车程。哈尔杜姆哈欠连天，难以保持清醒，但他忽视了黑泽尔要求靠边停车休息的请求。突然，两只袋鼠从车前跳了出来。哈尔杜姆猛地打方向盘，导致汽车失控并在侧翻了五次后倒下。他们从残骸中逃生时基本毫发无损，但黑泽尔的双腿、躯干和一些
internal organs were crushed. Two-year-old Lauren sustained minor injuries, however, nine-year-old Willow and seven-year-old Ryan were thrown from the vehicle and died instantly. Toxicology tests confirmed the presence of amphetamines in Haldum's system, which he claimed he had taken days earlier. Hazel's left leg was amputated, leaving her permanently wheelchair-bound. As she recovered in hospital, Haldum paid her a visit accompanied by Carly and Candleese. Describing Haldum and Carly as, quote, really chummy, Hazel was certain the two were having
内脏被压碎。两岁的劳伦受了轻伤，然而九岁的威洛和七岁的瑞安被甩出车外，当场身亡。毒理学检测证实哈尔杜姆体内存在安非他命成分，他声称这是几天前服用的。黑泽尔的左腿被截肢，导致她终身残疾只能坐轮椅。当她在医院康复时，哈尔杜姆在卡莉和坎德利斯的陪同下前去探望。黑泽尔形容哈尔杜姆和卡莉“十分亲密”，她确信这两人有
an affair and ended her relationship with Haldum. Following the funeral for Hazel's two children on November 14, Haldum fled to Canberra with Carly and Candleese, believing police would press charges against him for the crash. Police tracked Hazel down to her Davern Park home in Adelaide's North. She explained that on December 20, 2008, Haldum reappeared in Adelaide alone and the pair resumed their relationship. Haldum would give conflicting stories regarding Carly's whereabouts, claiming she was in Alice Springs, Canberra and Queensland.
染并结束了与哈尔杜姆的关系。11月14日黑泽尔的两个孩子葬礼结束后，哈尔杜姆带着卡莉和坎德利斯逃往堪培拉，以为警方会就车祸对他提起指控。警方在阿德莱德北部的达弗恩公园家中找到了黑泽尔。她解释说，2008年12月20日，哈尔杜姆独自重新出现在阿德莱德，两人复合了。哈尔杜姆就卡莉的下落给出了相互矛盾的说法，声称她在艾丽斯斯普林斯、堪培拉和昆士兰。
According to Hazel, Haldum had a pornography addiction and had pedophilic content on his computer pertaining to underage girls. The now 41-year-old Daniel Haldum was currently serving four years at Cessnaw Correctional Centre in New South Wales for raping a nine-year-old girl in 2013. Haldum's criminal record dated back to his early 20s with offences for drink driving, theft, fraud and domestic violence. Drug and alcohol addictions increased his violent tendencies and led to the deterioration of his first marriage.
据黑泽尔称，哈尔杜姆有色情成瘾，他的电脑里有关于未成年女孩的恋童癖内容。现年41岁的丹尼尔·哈尔杜姆目前正在新南威尔士州的塞斯诺克惩教中心服刑四年，罪名是在2013年强奸了一名九岁女孩。哈尔杜姆的犯罪记录可以追溯到他二十出头的时候，罪行包括酒后驾车、盗窃、欺诈和家庭暴力。对毒品和酒精的成瘾加剧了他的暴力倾向，并导致他第一段婚姻的破裂。
He adopted a transient lifestyle thereafter before arriving in Alice Springs with Hazel Passmore in 2007. Haldum was interviewed in prison, telling police his relationship with Carly was built on a foundation of support following the car crash that claimed the lives of his two step-children, but ended within two months over financial matters. He sold her car and used her bank card to settle a debt with his cousin before returning to Adelaide to resume his relationship with Hazel. He claimed he maintained an affair with Carly up until 2009.
此后，他过上了漂泊不定的生活，直到2007年与黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔一起抵达艾丽斯斯普林斯。哈尔杜姆在监狱中接受了讯问，他告诉警方，他与卡莉的关系是建立在车祸夺去他两个继子生命后相互支持的基础上的，但两个月后因经济问题而结束。他卖掉了她的车，并用她的银行卡偿还了欠表弟的债务，然后返回阿德莱德与黑泽尔复合。他声称自己与卡莉保持婚外情直至2009年。
After that year, she informed him she was moving to Queensland to be with another man. Haldum's story changed multiple times throughout the interview, and he often contradicted himself, though he denied any involvement in Carly or Candelice's murder, or that he had conspired with Hazel to steal Carly's identity and access her finances. Police executed search warrants at multiple properties associated with Haldum, finding Candelice's birth certificate, Carly's Medicare and library cards, and her mobile phone. Several notebooks were filled with sexually explicit stories, many of which featured young women and children.
那一年之后，她通知他她要搬去昆士兰和另一个人在一起。在整个讯问过程中，哈尔杜姆的说法多次改变，且经常自相矛盾，不过他否认参与杀害卡莉或坎德利斯，也否认曾与黑泽尔串谋盗用卡莉的身份并动用她的资金。警方对与哈尔杜姆相关的多处房产执行了搜查令，找到了坎德利斯的出生证明、卡莉的医疗卡和图书馆卡以及她的手机。几个笔记本上写满了色情露骨的故事，其中许多故事的主角都是年轻女性和儿童。
A handwriting expert concluded Haldum authored most, but several were written by Hazel Passmore. According to the book The Lost Girls by Ava Benny Morrison, when questioned, Hazel claimed she wrote the stories that Haldum's request is a form of foreplay, and that Haldum would ask her to recount her own childhood sexual abuse to get himself aroused. One notebook contained a list of about 30 children identified by their age, first names and locations, which included places where Haldum stayed throughout 2006 and 2007. Alongside the names, Haldum had written the words Consent, Forced, or Rape. The list included the name Candles, but there was no evidence to indicate he had assaulted
一名笔迹专家得出结论认为，大部分内容由哈尔杜姆执笔，但有几篇是黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔写的。根据Ava Benny Morrison所著的《失踪女孩》一书，当被讯问时，黑泽尔声称她写这些故事是因为哈尔杜姆的要求是一种前戏，哈尔杜姆会要求她复述自己童年遭受性虐待的经历来激起他的性欲。其中一个笔记本包含了一份大约30名儿童的名单，标明了他们的年龄、名字和所在地，其中包括哈尔杜姆在2006年和2007年期间停留过的地方。在名字旁边，哈尔杜姆写下了“同意”、“强迫”或“强奸”等字眼。这份名单中包括名字坎德斯，但没有证据表明他曾袭击过
any other children mentioned, and the list was ultimately determined to be a fictitious fantasy, just further evidence of Haldum's pedophilic inclinations. Police also seized a diary written by a 17-year-old who Haldum was in a relationship with at the time of his arrest for rape in 2013. One entry dated January 8, 2013, read, Daniel lied to me, said he killed Carly and Candle, but they're still alive. It's all over Facebook, but he says they're dead and he made them think she's alive. Everything he says doesn't make sense.
名单上提到的任何其他儿童，该名单最终被确认为虚构的幻想，只是哈尔杜姆恋童倾向的又一证据。警方还查获了一名17岁女孩写的日记，在2013年哈尔杜姆因强奸罪被捕时，这名女孩正与他交往。2013年1月8日的一篇日记写道：“丹尼尔对我说谎，说他杀害了卡莉和坎德尔，但她们还活着。这在Facebook上到处都是，但他却说她们死了，并让她以为她还活着。他说的每句话都毫无逻辑。”
Apparently he killed her in December 2008, but people gave her money on her daughter's birthday in 2010 and 2011. Got a text from Hazel saying they're dead and she's seeing pics. Hazel had come across a camera's SD memory card belonging to Haldum that allegedly contained child pornography and compromising images of Carly. She confiscated it and later gave it to a relative in case something happened to her. The card itself was handed into police. Photographs of Haldum and people known to him had been deleted from the card, while images
显然他在2008年12月杀害了她，但在2010年和2011年女儿生日时，人们还给她的账户汇过钱。收到黑泽尔发来的一条短信，说她们死了，她看到了照片。黑泽尔偶然发现了属于哈尔杜姆的一个相机SD存储卡，里面据称存有儿童色情制品和卡莉的私密照片。她没收了这张卡，后来交给了一位亲戚，以防自己发生不测。这张卡本身已经交给了警方。卡中哈尔杜姆及其熟人的照片已被删除，而图像则
of various properties where he had resided throughout his adult life remained. One photo showed a skull fragment belonging to one of Hazel's two deceased children, having been taken at the scene of the car crash in 2008. There were also pictures of Carly timestamped the morning of Monday, December 15, 2008. She was wearing the white angelic t-shirt that was found with her remains. These compared the images to those of the Belanglo crime scene. Carly's skeletal remains were in a near identical position to the way her body lay in the photographs, which depicted the brutalization inflicted upon her, including a foot pressed against
在他成年后居住过的各种房产中还保留着。其中一张照片显示了属于黑泽尔两个已故孩子之一的头骨碎片，这是2008年在车祸现场拍摄的。还有2008年12月15日星期一早晨带有时间戳的卡莉的照片。她穿着和遗骸一起被发现的白色天使T恤。这些照片与贝兰格洛犯罪现场的照片进行了对比。卡莉的骨骼遗骸的位置与照片中她身体躺着的位置几乎完全一致，照片描绘了对她施加的残酷虐待，包括一只脚踩在
her neck. On October 28, Daniel Haldum requested a second interview with investigators, during which he claimed he wanted to come clean. He proceeded to implicate the boyfriend of his cousin Christine in the murders. As he was providing this information, police received word that Haldum's phone records placed him near Belanglo State Forest within the timeframe the photographs of Carly's attack were taken. He was subsequently arrested and charged with her murder, telling officers,
她的脖子上。10月28日，丹尼尔·霍尔杜姆要求与调查人员进行第二次面谈，期间他声称自己想坦白一切。他接着指控他的表妹克里斯蒂娜的男友参与了谋杀。在他提供这些信息的同时，警察接到消息称，霍尔杜姆的通话记录显示他在拍摄卡莉遇害照片的时间段内位于贝兰格洛州立森林附近。他随后被捕并被控谋杀她，他对警官们说，
You've got the wrong guy. You'll see. Investigators were certain Candice was murdered after her mother, but had yet to establish the exact time and location of that crime. According to the book The Lost Girls, police offered Hazel Passmore a deal, tell the truth, and none of the information provided would be used to build a case against her. She agreed. Revealing that in mid-2009 she had discovered Carly's belongings in the boot of Haldum's
你们抓错人了。你们会知道的。调查人员确信坎迪斯是在她母亲之后被遇害的，但尚未确定该罪行的确切时间和地点。根据《失踪女孩》一书，警方与黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔达成了一项协议：说出真相，所提供的信息将全部不会用于建立针对她的案件。她表示同意。她透露，在2009年中期，她在霍尔杜姆的
car. Believing the pair had resumed their affair, she confronted Haldum, who told her not to worry about Carly anymore, as she was dead. He then described in detail how he had killed her. Hazel remained uncertain that Haldum was telling the truth, until she came across the incriminating photographs of Carly on the SD card, showing her death in the exact manner he described. Hazel asked him about Candice, and Haldum explained he had suffocated her, sexually abused her body, then dumped her somewhere on the highway.
汽车后备箱里发现了卡莉的随身物品。由于相信两人已经恢复了私情，她质问了霍尔杜姆，霍尔杜姆告诉她不用再担心卡莉了，因为她已经死了。随后，他详细描述了他是如何杀死她的。黑泽尔仍然不确信霍尔杜姆说的是实话，直到她在一张SD卡上偶然发现了卡莉的不利照片，上面显示了她以他所描述的精确方式死亡的过程。黑泽尔向他询问坎迪斯的情况，霍尔杜姆解释说他闷死了她，对她的尸体进行了性虐待，然后将她扔在了高速公路的某处。
When news broke in 2015 that a toddler's body had been found on the Corunda Highway, Hazel wondered if it was Candice, but was too afraid to contact authorities. She told the police Haldum killed Carly so that he could come back to her, quote, he did it for me, it was all me. Hazel admitted to accompanying Haldum to Centrelink and the bank pretending to be Carly in order to gain her single-parent benefits, rent assistance, Medicare rebates, credit card and savings, but claimed she did so under duress. Despite evidence to the contrary, she denied speaking to Carly's family on the phone and
当2015年有消息称在科伦达高速公路上发现了一具幼儿尸体时，黑泽尔想知道这是否是坎迪斯，但又太害怕而不敢联系当局。她告诉警方霍尔杜姆杀害卡莉是为了能回到她身边，引用原话，“他是为了我做的，全都是为了我。”黑泽尔承认曾陪同霍尔杜姆前往申领中心和银行，假装是卡莉，以便获取她的单亲福利、租金补助、医疗保险退税、信用卡和存款，但她声称自己是在胁迫下这样做的。尽管有相反的证据，她还是否认在电话中与卡莉的家人交谈并
pretending to be her during calls. She then told police, Carly destroyed everything I had and I hated her, if I could have ripped money off her, I would have done. Hazel denied spending Carly's money herself, saying it was used exclusively by Haldum to pay rent and living expenses. Overall, Haldum had obtained more than $72,000 from Carly's accounts. On Sunday, December 13, 2015, Carly and Candice were farewelled at the Alice Springs Desert Church.
在通话期间假装是她。她随后告诉警方，“卡莉毁了我拥有的一切，我恨她，如果我能从她身上榨取钱财，我就会这么做。”黑泽尔否认自己花过卡莉的钱，称这些钱完全被霍尔杜姆用来支付房租和生活费。总的来说，霍尔杜姆从卡莉的账户中获取了超过72,000美元。2015年12月13日星期日，卡莉和坎迪斯在爱丽丝泉沙漠教堂告别。
A statement from their family thanked the community for their support, saying, Many throughout Australia pray that mother and daughter will now rest forever in the arms of the angels. It described Carly as a cheeky, kind and loyal young woman who was always there to support her family. Although she was small in stature, Carly's heart and personality were described as huge and she was commended for her optimism. Two-year-old Candice had been the center of attention and idolized her grandparents.
他们家人的声明感谢了社区的支持，并写道：“全澳大利亚的许多人都祈祷母亲和女儿现在能永远在天使的怀抱中安息。”声明将卡莉描述为一个厚颜无耻、善良而忠诚的年轻女性，总是随时准备支持她的家人。尽管她身材娇小，但卡莉的心胸和性格却被形容为无比宏大，她的乐观精神也受到了赞扬。两岁的坎迪斯曾是人们关注的焦点，并把她的祖父母当作偶像崇拜。
Together, the pair were, quote, facing the world with all its charms, persuasions and pitfalls. Over 100 mourners donned the pair's favorite colors, pink and blue, as they were laid to rest side by side in a single white coffin. They were buried alongside Carly's mother, Colleen, fulfilling her final wish to be reunited with her daughter and granddaughter. Their shared headstone read, In our hearts and each other's arms forever. Two days later, Daniel Holdum was charged with the murder of Candice Pierce.
两人在一起，引用原话，“带着它所有的魅力、诱惑和陷阱勇敢面对世界。”100多名哀悼者身着这对母女最喜欢的颜色——粉色和蓝色，将她们并排安葬在一个单一的白色棺材里。她们与卡莉的母亲科琳合葬在一起，实现了她与女儿和孙女团聚的最后愿望。她们共同的墓碑上写着：“永远在我们心中和彼此的怀抱中。”两天后，丹尼尔·霍尔杜姆被控谋杀坎迪斯·皮尔斯。
The prosecution's case relied heavily on circumstantial evidence, including Hazel Passmore's confession. Investigators endeavored to build a stronger case by determining the exact location and circumstances of the toddler's murder. According to witness statements, Holdum left his cousin's Canberra-based property with Candice on Friday, December 19, 2008, four days after Carly was killed. When he arrived at Hazel Passmore's Adelaide home the following day, he was alone. Holdum's movements were tracked by his mobile phone and credit card data, revealing he spent
控方的案子严重依赖间接证据，包括黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔的供词。调查人员努力通过确定幼儿谋杀案的确切地点和情况来建立更有力的案子。根据证人证言，霍尔杜姆于2008年12月19日星期五带着坎迪斯离开了他表妹位于堪培拉的房产，此时距离卡莉遇害已经过去四天。第二天他抵达黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔位于阿德莱德的家时，只有他一个人。霍尔杜姆的行踪通过他的手机和信用卡数据进行了追踪，显示他在
an hour in the New South Wales Regional Hub of Wagga Wagga on the morning of December 19, where he visited the local Woolworth supermarket to purchase garbage bags, silver home handyman brand duct tape, and multi-purpose wipes. The duct tape and wipes were an exact match to those bound with Candice's remains. He then drove another hour to the riverside town of Narendra and checked into the midtown motor inn at 11am under the alias Daniel Marshall, plus one child. Despite paying for a night's stay, mobile data showed he left two and a half hours later, continuing onwards to South Australia.
12月19日早晨在新南威尔士州区域枢纽沃加沃加逗留了一个小时，在那里他参观了当地的伍尔沃斯超市，购买了垃圾袋、银色家居杂工品牌胶带和多用途湿巾。这些胶带和湿巾与捆绑坎迪斯遗骸的物品完全吻合。随后，他又驱车一小时前往河畔小镇纳伦德拉，并于上午11点以丹尼尔·马歇尔及一名儿童的化名入住中城汽车旅馆。尽管支付了一晚的住宿费用，但手机数据显示他在两个半小时后就离开了，继续前往南澳大利亚州。
The motel had since changed management, and investigators were unable to detect any forensic evidence in the room where Holdum briefly stayed. They tracked down the previous owners, who confirmed that in 2008, the motel was stocked with purple bath towels, whose brand and batch number matched the one wrapped around Candice's body. Police were certain Holdum murdered the toddler in the motel room before placing her body in the suitcase, which he disposed of as he journeyed to Adelaide. Daniel Holdum pled not guilty and went to great lengths to delay court proceedings, from
该汽车旅馆此后更换了管理层，调查人员无法在霍尔杜姆短暂停留的房间里检测到任何法医证据。他们追踪了前任业主，对方确认在2008年时，该旅馆备有紫色浴巾，其品牌和批号与包裹坎迪斯尸体的浴巾相符。警方确信霍尔杜姆是在汽车旅馆房间里谋杀这名幼儿的，然后将她的尸体放进手提箱里，并在前往阿德莱德的途中将其处理掉。丹尼尔·霍尔杜姆不认罪，并竭尽全力拖延法庭诉讼程序，从
firing his legal team to intentionally leaving important documents in his prison cell. His trial was scheduled for August the following year, but a week before it was due to commence, Holdum unexpectedly changed his plea to guilty, hoping it would ultimately result in a reduced prison sentence. He made one final effort to delay the inevitable when his sentencing date arrived on November 30, 2018, requesting to revert his plea for Candice's murder back to not guilty. His application was rejected. A document titled, Facts in the Crown Case Not Disputed by the Defense, listed a number
解雇他的法律团队到故意将重要文件留在他的监狱牢房里。他的审判原定于第二年8月举行，但在审判开始前一周，霍尔杜姆出人意料地将他的抗辩改为认罪，希望这最终能导致减刑。当2018年11月30日他的判决日期到来时，他为推迟不可避免的事情进行了最后一次努力，请求将他关于谋杀坎迪斯的抗辩改回不认罪。他的申请被驳回了。一份名为《辩方不具争议的皇家案件事实》的文件列出了
of assertions by the prosecution that Holdum had agreed to, including he was, quote, attempting to or planning to sexually assault Candice at the time of her death. He admitted to using Carly's mobile phone to give the impression she was still alive, sending a flurry of messages immediately after her mother reported her missing and using the device up until May 2011. Holdum's defense team argued that their client's actions were the result of an unstable upbringing that had negatively impacted his adult life. Forensic psychiatrist Dr. Ullard Nielsen interviewed Holdum during his incarceration,
霍尔杜姆同意的一系列控方断言，其中包括他，引用原话，“在死亡时企图或计划对坎迪斯进行性侵犯。”他承认使用卡莉的手机给人一种她还活着的印象，在她母亲报告她失踪后立即发送了一连串的信息，并一直使用该设备直到2011年5月。霍尔杜姆的辩护团队辩称，他们当事人的行为是不稳定的成长环境的结果，这对其成年生活产生了负面影响。法医精神病学家厄拉德·尼尔森博士在霍尔杜姆收押期间对他进行了面谈，
diagnosing him with depression and a probable personality disorder, citing a childhood marred by abuse, neglect, foster care, and substance use. By the time he reached his teens, Holdum was a delinquent who often initiated fights with peers, participated in drug-taking, and had weekly contact with the police. One therapist who saw Holdum during ages 13 to 14 described him as a very damaged, young boy. Holdum provided Dr. Nielsen with his own version of events, starting on December 14, 2008, when he and Carly went driving late at night to, quote, go sightseeing and have a good
诊断他患有抑郁症和可能的人格障碍，并指出他有一个饱受虐待、忽视、寄养和药物滥用蹂躏的童年。到了青少年时期，霍尔杜姆成了一个经常挑起同龄人打架、参与吸毒并每周与警方接触的问题少年。一位在霍尔杜姆13至14岁时看过他的治疗师将他形容为一个非常受损的年轻男孩。霍尔杜姆向尼尔森博士提供了他自己版本的事件经过，始于2008年12月14日，当时他和卡莉深夜开车出去，引用原话，“去观光并度过美好
time. They pulled off the highway and into Belanglo State Forest, arriving at around 5am the next morning. An argument broke out, and Carly threatened to tell Hazel how long their affair had been going on for. Outraged, Holdum became violent, grabbing a broom handle from the car and hitting Carly across the rib cage. She vomited blood, causing him to panic and drive off, leaving her behind.
时光。”他们把车开出高速公路，驶入贝兰格洛州立森林，于次日凌晨5点左右抵达。争吵爆发了，卡莉威胁要告诉黑泽尔他们私情持续了多久。大发雷霆的霍尔杜姆变得暴力起来，从车里抓起一根扫帚柄打在卡莉的胸腔上。她吐血了，这让他惊慌失措并驱车离去，把她抛在了身后。
He maintained she was still alive when he left, but knew she would die soon after. He admitted to being affected by ecstasy and methamphetamine, which he claimed put him in a volatile state. As for Candice, Holdum said, it's horrible, I guess. She got suffocated. Justice Robert Allen Hume refused to accept Holdum's accounts, calling them substantially inaccurate based on undisputed facts. These injuries were akin to being stomped or kneaded to the chest, and Holdum's claim
他坚称他离开时她还活着，但他知道她很快就会死。他承认自己受到了摇头丸和甲基安非他命的影响，他声称这让他处于一种喜怒无常的状态。至于坎迪斯，霍尔杜姆说：“这太可怕了，我想。她被闷死了。”法官罗伯特·艾伦·休姆拒绝接受霍尔杜姆的供词，根据无可争议的事实，称其基本不准确。这些伤势类似于胸部被踩踏或揉捏，而霍尔杜姆声称
that she was alive and vomiting blood before he abandoned her were disputed by the photographs he took, which showed her clearly deceased body with no visible blood. The judge thought it unfortunate that Dr. Nielsen did not ask Holdum to explain matters such as why he took the photographs or did the things they depicted. Furthermore, information provided by Holdum to different doctors was inexplicably inconsistent. He provided three separate accounts of his father's death, variously stating that he was 20, 18, and 15 at the time. He also claimed the duration of his relationship with Hazel Passmore was four years, then eleven
在她被遗弃前她还活着并吐血的说法，被他拍摄的照片所反驳，照片显示她明显已经死亡且没有可见的血液。法官认为遗憾的是，尼尔森博士没有要求霍尔杜姆解释诸如他为什么拍照或做照片所描绘的事情之类的问题。此外，霍尔杜姆向不同医生提供的信息存在莫名其妙的不一致。他提供了关于他父亲死因的三种不同说法，分别声称他在当时是20岁、18岁和15岁。他还声称他与黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔的关系持续了四年，然后是十一年
years, and asserted that he was never unfaithful, despite telling Dr. Nielsen his relationship with Carly began when he was still living with Hazel. Judge Hume was left to question Holdum's credibility, which was already shaky given his history of dishonesty and fraud offences, and his capability of deceiving others when it served his purpose. As Holdum showed no signs of remorse, the judge ruled. I am satisfied that the offender's actions were deliberate, purposeful, and subject of some prior consideration.
年，并坚称自己从未不忠，尽管他曾告诉尼尔森博士，他和卡莉的关系始于他还在和黑泽尔住在一起的时候。休姆法官不得不质疑霍尔杜姆的可信度，鉴于他有不诚实和欺诈犯罪的历史，以及在符合其目的时欺骗他人的能力，他的可信度本已摇摇欲坠。由于霍尔杜姆没有表现出丝毫悔意，法官裁决道：“我确信罪犯的行为是蓄意的、有目的的，并且经过了一些事先的考虑。”
I am satisfied that the offender completely understood what he was doing and its wrongfulness. Victim impact statements spoke of the pain suffered by Carly and Candelisa's loved ones during their lengthy disappearance. They described the hurt they felt at having been led to believe that Carly no longer wanted anything to do with her family. Carly's biological father, Bruce Pearce, directed part of his statement at Holdum, quote, The hate that I feel is consuming, I have never hated anyone the way that I hate you.
“我确信罪犯完全明白自己在做什么及其错误性。”受害人影响陈述讲述了卡莉和坎迪莉萨的亲人在她们长期失踪期间所遭受的痛苦。他们描述了因被误导认为卡莉不再希望与家人有任何瓜葛而感到的伤害。卡莉的亲生父亲布鲁斯·皮尔斯在陈述中有一部分是针对霍尔杜姆的，引用原话，“我感受到的仇恨是吞噬性的，我从未像恨你这样恨过任何人。”
The thoughts of what the girls went through, the anger I feel, turns to physical pain, it hurts to breathe. I would like to see the death penalty for you, but even that would not be enough. Scott Povey said that when he heard his stepdaughter and granddaughter had been murdered, quote, My heart was ripped out of me and my soul torn out of existence. Judge Hume accepted the prosecution's submission that Holdum's crimes were motivated by several factors, sexual, financial, and, as evident by him keeping the photographs of the indignities in inflicted on Carly, the thrill of the kill.
“想到女孩们经历的事情，我感受到的愤怒，转化成了身体上的疼痛，呼吸都觉得痛。我希望看到对你处以死刑，但即使那样也不够。”斯科特·坡维表示，当他听说他的继女和孙女被谋杀时，引用原话，“我的心被从我身上撕裂，我的灵魂被撕出了生存的范畴。”休姆法官接受了控方的意见，即霍尔杜姆的谋杀动机是由多种因素驱动的：性、金钱，以及从他保留卡莉受辱照片中显而易见的那种杀戮的刺激。
While the exact cause of Candelisa's death couldn't be determined, Judge Hume had no doubt she suffered significantly and her death was likely prompted, at least in part, by Holdum's need to cover up the murder of Carly. Judge Hume, quote, The last moments of Carly's life must have been horrendous. She was physically separated from her child, alone in an isolated location in a forest with a man she had trusted and had romantic feelings for. His treatment of her showed complete disdain for her existence as a human being.
虽然坎迪莉萨的确切死因无法确定，但休姆法官毫无疑问她遭受了沉重的痛苦，并且她的死至少部分是由霍尔杜姆为了掩盖对卡莉的谋杀而促成的。休姆法官，引用原话：“卡莉生命的最后时刻一定极其可怕。她与她的孩子在身体上被分离，独自在一个偏僻的森林里，和一个她曾经信任并产生过浪漫情感的男人在一起。他对她的对待表现出对她作为人类存在的完全蔑视。”
To him, she was just flesh with a life that could be extinguished for his vile pleasure. Even without being able to be satisfied beyond reasonable doubt what it was that motivated the offender to do what he did, I am satisfied that the manner in which the offender killed Carly Pierce Stevenson and the circumstances in which it occurred amount to a murder of extreme gravity and appalling depravity. It is a murder at the top of the range of objective seriousness. Daniel Holdum was sentenced to life imprisonment for the murders of Candelise Pierce and Carly Pierce Stevenson.
对她而言，她只是一具可以为了他邪恶的快感而熄灭生命的肉体。即使无法在排除合理怀疑的情况下确信究竟是什么动机促使罪犯做出了他所做的事情，我也确信罪犯杀害卡莉·皮尔斯·史蒂文森的方式以及发生的环境构成了一起极端严重且骇人听闻的谋杀案。这是一起处于客观严重性范围顶端的谋杀案。丹尼尔·霍尔杜姆因谋杀坎迪莉萨·皮尔斯和卡莉·皮尔斯·史蒂文森而被判处终身监禁。
Outside court, a statement delivered on behalf of the victim's family read, No sentence will ever bring closure. He murdered a young mother and her child. He stole their whole lives from them and from us. We live daily without Carly and Candelise and will do so for the rest of our lives. His brutality will haunt us forever. Exactly how the suitcase containing Candelise's body went unnoticed for almost a decade along Corunda Highway remains unknown.
在法庭外，代表受害者家属发表的一份声明写道：“任何判决都永远不会带来心灵的闭环。他谋杀了一位年轻的母亲和她的孩子。他夺走了他们的一生，也夺走了我们的一生。我们的日常生活没有卡莉和坎迪莉萨，余生也将如此。他的残暴将永远萦绕在我们心头。”装有坎迪莉萨尸体的手提箱是如何在科伦达高速公路旁近十年未被注意到的，目前仍然未知。
Holdum said he left it on the side of the road in 2008, but nobody noticed the suitcase until 2015. Reports of a well-dressed 60-year-old man sent carrying a matching suitcase on the outskirts of Buonaca earlier that year remain a mystery, as he has never been identified. No charges were ever laid against Hazel Passmore. In 2016, she reached an out-of-court settlement with Holdum for an undisclosed amount for damages in relation to the 2008 car crash. Commissioner for Victim Rights Michael O'Connell worked closely with the police when they were
霍尔杜姆说他在2008年把它留在了路边，但直到2015年才有人注意到这个手提箱。当年早些时候，有报道称一名衣着得体的60岁男子提着一个相匹配的手提箱在布奥纳卡郊外行走，这仍然是一个谜，因为他从未被识别身份。黑泽尔·帕斯莫尔从未受到任何指控。2016年，她就2008年的车祸造成的损害与霍尔杜姆达成了一项未公开金额的庭外和解。受害者权利专员迈克尔·奥康奈尔在警方正在
in the process of identifying Candelise Pierce. In a 2019 interview with Channel 9 current affairs program 60 Minutes, Michael said, This has been the saddest case that I've encountered. This man not only took one human being's life, but he took two, a mother and child. He stole their lives and he stole the opportunities that the family had to share those lives with them. The lowest of the low is kind words, in my opinion. An obituary for the mother and daughter is signed off by the names of loving family members
确认坎迪莉萨·皮尔斯身份的过程中与警方密切合作。在2019年接受第九频道时事节目《60分钟》采访时，迈克尔说：“这是我遇到过的最悲伤的案子。这个男人不仅夺去了一个人的生命，而且夺去了两个人的生命，一个母亲和一个孩子。他夺走了他们的生命，也夺走了这个家庭与他们分享这些生命的机会。在我看来，‘人渣中的人渣’都算是好听的话了。”母亲和女儿的讣告由亲爱的家属签名
coupled with the message. Not a day goes by that we don't think about you, our angels, Carly and Candelise. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并附上了这样一条信息：“没有一天我们不想念你们，我们的天使，卡莉和坎迪莉萨。”这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。